there are many things I love about you
but since you first started coming on
the show years and years and years ago
with a set 70 show you would always talk
about how you're just a very practical
person and you know I meet a lot of
celebrities that live in this kooky
bubble and no one's more practical and
down-to-earth than you are I mean I mean
that and then really like you're very
you're very and you're frugal and you
like to do things on your own
last time you were here you said that
you got your wedding rings on Etsy true
that is so cool yeah that's you just
went with the band's yeah yeah did you
ever sell stuff on Etsy and when you do
that do they ever know it's you do they
well funny you should ask that I didn't
they didn't so when I was selling things
on the interwebs it was before it's
existed and my girlfriend Julie was like
I need to make extra cash come help and
I was like okay so we started a business
on eBay selling really crappy shirts
with like iron-on like in sync or
Backstreet Boys or like I love you mom
you may you may be where to god there's
probably hundreds of them out there in
someone's garage like we would go to
downtown LA and buy like t-shirts and
tank tops for like two cents and then
buy iron-ons why we printed out in an
iron-on whatever image at that time the
number one image was Backstreet Boys and
NSYNC and then charge like $12.99 for
shipping and handling included and ship
out these really crappy t-shirts on eBay
you don't I love is it this is while you
were a television star on that 70 show
oh yeah you had a sweatshop set up
and you're cranking out illegal t-shirts
but you can't do that you can't be like
Backstreet Boys don't worry they'll get
their cut you know legal we were buying
it off of like the t-shirts off of like
a truck in downtown and nothing was
legal did you make what was your company
did you make good money I didn't get
anything out of it what no my girlfriend
Julie kept all the money I was just like
hanging out like I think what's wrong
with you
you never asked she was like oh this is
really fun isn't it and she's driving
around in a Bentley and you're this he
was gonna end up bringing my Julie but
Julie is one of my oldest oldest best
friends and she used to get me to do the
dumbest things like she used to run a
store at the Beverly Center which is a
mall here and the store no longer exists
it was called natural wonder and she
would like during Christmas time it
would get really busy and she's like
just come in and wrap some gifts and I
was like yeah okay and like while on
that 70 show people would recognize
you'd be getting their gift comment yes
it was horrible it was like and she
would make me wear an apron and I was
like hey welcome to natural wonder what
it's no big deal just keep walking would
you like a moon rock this rock came from
the moon like a little yeah wait you
know everyone probably thought that you
had you were in terrible financial no I
mean that would be the natural
assumption when you see a TV star
working in a mall you know what I mean I
think that's really cool it's so it's
weird I mean I did all that yes I also
worked it right it we talked about this
I you know works a lot for free yeah for
free don't do that
[Applause]
you